let's jump to this next story we'll
start talking about families we have
this from the post millennial paramount
plus sponsors drag event where child
dances on stage for money
ladies and gentlemen um
just pull up the wikipedia entry for
stripper and i can't do it here because
it does have nude women in the wikipedia
but uh
what you need to understand is that
stripping does not mean being nude right
some strippers can't take their clothes
off but they're still considered
strippers they call them bikini bars the
wikipedia entry actually shows it says
bikini and gogo dancing and it says the
women have to be fully clothed they have
to cover their tops and bottoms
they dance on stage and people give them
money at this event
it was a uh
rupaul uh rupaul's drag kong
they had two children on stage and this
little boy was jumping and dancing
around and taking money from people
this is grooming
this kid what they do is they put this
kid in an environment and they say it's
innocent there's nothing sexual about it
the kid then gets uh he they normalize
the behavior of dancing on stage for
money from the audience
the way grooming would work i'm not
saying they will do to this kid but the
way it would work is that after you do
this when the kid gets a little older
you then say hey it's going to be a swim
a swimsuit show we're doing a take your
shirt off
then
they give you money then oh we're going
to do we're going to do another swimsuit
thing but this one you got you have to
wear these special swimsuits and then
they give them speedos or something
that's how grooming works they it works
on adults
there are people who are groomed into
being
sex workers
through this this is not the most
egregious thing we've seen there was
desmond is amazing who quite literally
removed clothing on stage
and then took money from people
at a bar full of adults
they're grooming your kids
paramount is sponsoring this discovery
plus is a child drag event this is this
is a reality
it's almost like there's a lot of
pedophiles in media or something like
that weird yeah well they normalize it
one step at a time and so here's the
goal they want you to look at this and
say well it's just people dancing you
know is it really that that's what
they'll say to you they'll say it's just
dancing right right they have to it's a
drag show it's a bunch of pervy dudes
dressing or like dressing up and trying
to act like they're female dancers
that's not innocent so what they'll do
is they'll say it's just like a costume
show what are you so mad about why are
you so obsessed i mean i wonder why you
care so much sheamus
yeah well that's the thing right like
let's expose children to this because we
care so much that it has to be forced
onto young ones and then when you point
out that there's something wrong with
that you're the one putting inordinate
attention on it
so
the family's been destroyed
there is a uh you know when i was
covering this in my my uh my tim cast
channel segment there was a photo of
drag queen story hour where there's
these liberal parents smiling and
laughing as they put their kids in front
of this
they're into it
they like it
i think it says something about where
the
parents are coming from of course and i
hope this was a parody account but it
reminds me of on twitter a couple of
years ago there's a woman
didn't say was a parody account who's
complaining at being attacked because
she had in her bio that she was
transgendering her
twin toddlers
i didn't even know what that meant i had
to think about it it just you know
billboard i think it's a big reason why
um
in virginia where i live that's why
you know we had glenn young can win i
was a volunteer on his campaign
and a lot of it had to do with the
schools and what was being taught in
schools and a lot of this gender
ideology which should not be taught in
schools it should be something if you as
a parent you have the right to teach
your children uh your values and terry
mcauliffe the democrat opponent said no
that uh they shouldn't be telling
teachers what to think so i think i mean
having worked on the campaign i was
there on election night it gave me a lot
of hope that there are a lot of parents
who are pushing back on this so
homeschool your kids yeah there's no
question about it at this point home
school yeah or private christian schools
or even then you really have to vet it
that's true too really
they have the christian schools have
some of the same accreditation
facilities that require them to do this
things you'd be surprised that the
public schools have to do
but there is a trend as you guys know
and destroying this in full measure
recently toward not just homeschooling
but there's pods now there's groups
there's organizations in the
neighborhood where they're getting
actual more formal group education just
outside the public school system
that parallel economy is forming people
are just deciding
they don't agree with it and if you keep
going too radical in the school system a
parallel system is going to develop i
think we're there with the schools it's
interesting because with the entire
public school
structure which you know has been
imitated by a lot of these private
schools as well the way the system has
been set up we take it for granted but
it really is very bizarre that the
status quo is such that
parents send their children
to go off with complete strangers
for basically the entire day for
basically their entire childhood that is
very strange and to learn not just stuff
we consider traditional education but
all of their social values and their
moral values and all the extra stuff
that as a parent you kind of want to do
yourself usually
yeah well i think unfortunately a lot of
parents don't i think unfortunately a
lot of parents don't want to do it
themselves it's very sad but i think it
happens a lot they don't want to have
uncomfortable conversations there are
people who will even say sex ed needs to
be taught in schools why well because i
don't have that conversation with my kid
what's wrong with you you want a
stranger to they were raised in that
system
that's also true that's fair it's a fair
point yeah who was who was it who was
talking about how kids who agrees to
grow up on a farm knew about the birds
and the bees because yes the animals
yeah i've mentioned that before well
when i was in high school another
student literally asked me the question
how did people learn about sex before
sex ed i'm not kidding wow like are you
i was like well because
people were a more closely connected to
nature b people figure out how to do
that on their own the reason you have
sex education the reason adults need to
talk to young people about that kind of
thing is to tell them what not to do
that's the whole point you're getting
older um
and x y and z
and this you should know that yes you
should be married to someone before you
do x y and z this makes children well
sheamus uh i think you got to be fair to
these people you see uh before the
advent of sex ed humans had no idea how
to repeat it yeah it's true
we didn't know what was causing we're
very lucky
we were very much like panda bears yeah
aliens came
and and taught us
about reproduction and then we wrote it
down in books and now we have to teach
kids otherwise who knows what will
happen well you know the other thing was
that we didn't know that men could get
pregnant
and that's something that we're only
just now learning and uh but i do have
to do a plug for the the bill that um we
talked about a little bit earlier and if
if you all watching can go to women's
bill of rights.com we are pushing back
on this at the federal level and also at
the state level so we just introduced a
week and a half ago a bill the women's
bill of rights
and it says
it's a resolution to codify that a woman
is a woman and we define what a woman is
uh their biological sex that she has a
uterus uh that she has you know female
reproductive organs it's really pathetic
that we have to spell this out but we're
doing it and so we've had several
members of congress
including a democrat katie porter from
pennsylvania so kudos to her
we're working also with the women's
liberation front which is a hard left
feminist group uh and as a conservative
group we want to work with women who
want to protect women's rights and then
we're also going to be moving it for the
next phase to the state level as well so
you can contact your local legislature
and say
we want this and i want it in my state
too we're doing at the federal level and
the state level so how do you define a
woman
well on the website we have it here it's
uh i can read it for purposes of state
federal law a person's sex is defined as
his or her biological sex either male or
female at birth
or purposes of state law
yes a female is an individual whose
biological reproductive system is
developed to produce ova a male is an
individual whose biological reproductive
system is developed to fertilize the ova
of a female for purpose of a state
federal law woman and girl refer to
human females and the term man and boy
refer to human males so simple well
there you go i actually think it's a
little complicated you know
because when you're mentioning you know
uterus and overall stuff i'm like you
could build one of those in the future
right take an animal's uterus and put it
in a the argument that they make is what
about a woman who has had a hysterectomy
now she's not a woman anymore and it's
like that argument yeah but but it it
works on weak-minded people yeah that's
why it's like adult human female and a
dull human male and they're like well
what's a male or what's a female oh you
want to read the biology of it all okay
now
yeah but even that and even that it goes
so much deeper right because it's not as
if we discovered the the xx and xy
chromosomes and went oh my gosh there's
two categories of people that we now
know about it's just been it's obvious
from the gecko it's insane that we have
to explain to people i think i think i
don't know if you made this point last
week was a really good point humans
didn't discover the x y x uh and x and y
chromosome until recently yeah but
humans always knew they were exactly
kinds of people it wasn't created as a
social construct for the purpose of you
know make oppressing people this is
something i assume since the beginning
of time although i wasn't there
that has been recognized and accepted
you know without being controversial
until really relatively recently i
wouldn't be surprised if we already are
already are starting to see the argument
where they say that the x and y
chromosomes aren't real and that they
were created to reinforce the
patriarchal gender binary
they will literally say science is
sexist yeah that's right exactly i say
it was a bunch of white men that's it
who needed a legal way to you know uh
what was called phrenology yeah with the
head measurement yeah they would measure
the heads yeah
like they wanted to justify racist ideas
so uh chromosomes
not a real thing as it turns out well
and this is because they do not use
language the way human beings are
supposed to use language they're not
trying to comp they're not trying to
communicate any kind of truth right so
when they talk about what a woman is
what insurrection is what terrorism is
what violence is they get it wrong
constantly right they call men and women
they call statements of fact about what
a person's biology is violence they call
it terror they don't call it terrorism
to tell someone that they should bomb a
public event that the former president
of the united states is going to be at
oh no it was a jew well he did get
really passionate and he walked it back
so i guess we're fine with it but they
they literally use it to try to signal
what they want it's very sad and it's
unbecoming it's degrading it's not how
humans are supposed to use language
that's actually kind of the way that
like dogs use language when you tell
your dog sit give me paw he doesn't
understand those words he knows he'll
get a treat and that's what we have
actual grown adult human beings walking
around doing using words and only
understanding them in the context that
gets them what they want instead of the
truth that's actually supposed to lie
beneath the phrasing so let's let's
let's dissect that a little bit what
you're saying is
the dog basically hears rumple and then
when he knows to respond to that sound
he'll get a treat but he doesn't
understand the concepts or ideas behind
what it means exactly so my dog does
yeah sure well yours is special your dog
is very special you have a colleague
right the cauli is the smartest breed i
think there you go i think i think i
don't i don't know if i agree with the
dog analogy thing i think it's fair to
say
you don't you don't need to use it you
say there are people who don't
understand what they're saying yeah they
just know that they can say certain
words and they'll be rewarded well
that's my point of point we had a
progressive on the show who said
conservatives are saying trans people
don't exist what and i said what does
that mean what and he was like huh
i'm like what does that mean like ben
shapiro knows blair white he knows she
exists what does that mean
they don't they don't think trans people
exist i'm like okay you're not telling
me anything and that's your point
exactly the only phrase to get their
point across to get what they want from
you to shame you instead of
communicating an actual idea that's like
transphobic as we've talked about um may
as well be a grunt exactly people called
transphobic often what the person
calling them that means is you don't
like the idea of
trans people but they're not afraid of
trans people they are not transphobic
i'm not sure how that word has become
just accepted into the lexicon the same
thing was homophobic yeah yeah like
you're scared of gay people not really
well it's interesting you made this
point that it could just be a grunt it's
really like any word could be a grunt we
make noises
and those noises are understood to have
certain meanings but what a human is
supposed to be able to do is is abstract
with those noises understand what they
mean use them honestly my point with a
dog analogy is whenever humans fail to
live up to their rational potential they
behave animalistically
you know i think
words
are oppressive uh english is a colonial
language and if we want to truly speak
in a way
that is representative of all human
cultures
clicks and whistles grunts yeah
yeah well that's honest and to be fair
when women aren't around that is how men
talk yeah yeah that's true we don't yeah
i'm sorry for your head out of the bag
there yeah yeah if you watch the um the
sheamus freedom tunes members only
you know we'll i'll i'll read the line
as dr fatchi like you have to wear your
mask and then i'll look up at champions
i have the antidote uh to your word
question and it's called the worktionary
oh so we made this product with the
independent women's network so you go to
iwnetwork.com
i'll give you this after the show you're
ready to have it yes it defines all
these terms like white adjacent systemic
racism triggered
uh restorative justice implicit bias
it's all here we spell it out the real
english we give the real definition of
women to your point i've asked people in
my orbit because i had to look this up
everybody's starting
years ago started saying equity equity
equity instead of equality i'm like but
no one explained that when journalists
adopt these phrases of advocacy i think
they better know what they're i think
they probably shouldn't usually because
it more thought should go into it you
can quote somebody but you shouldn't be
adopting it and i looked up equity and
it's as you guys probably know but i
think a lot of ordinary folks we don't
totally different than equality and if
you ask young people using that phrase
and it's just you know ubiquitous today
most people can't define equity versus
equality exactly because they don't need
to you say the word you get to treat
well it's equal outcomes versus equal
opportunity that's equity is socialism
equality is equality of opportunity
meritocracy exactly they do not like
meritocracy at all no that's what equity
to me is the notion of you predefine
people based on your understanding
without knowing somebody of what their
skill set is or what their abilities are
and you tell them
based on something like skin color
that they can't do something as well as
everybody else and they need help i mean
that's that's how i describe equity
where there are other people who don't
and that you're telling to me it's
almost the opposite of what the goal is
because you're labeling a certain group
of people based on nothing but well if
you if you look at the arguments they
make it's one group has privileges and
so they should be held back other groups
have disadvantages so they should be
pushed forward so equity is hobble those
who are successful it's kind of a tall
grass it's it's it's typical communist
ideology yeah exactly and in that is a
kid in america who in my generation we
were all told whatever color we were
this was our thing as you can be
anything and we that's what we thought i
hear women today talking about
you know i want my daughter to know that
you know women could even be doctors i'm
like we knew that in the 1960s like who
told you
in 1990 or 2000 that that wasn't
possible because we've been through all
there
i really don't think they think about
they're living in an insane fantasy land
they have a persecution complex
everything's the handmaid's tell right
there there was some comment that
someone posted where it's this little
black girl is in school and she's asked
what she wants to be when she grows up
or something she says i want to be an
astronaut the teacher goes that's great
and she goes what the teachers are like
that's that's fantastic and the girl
says no you're supposed to tell me i
can't do it because i'm a woman
and she was like but you can do it it
doesn't matter and then she was like you
know this famous astronaut that i'm a
big fan of was told she couldn't do it
so she you know fought against it and
rose to be the best and she was like yes
and because of her you now
can do it no one's holding you back and
then it just shows like the panel the
girl like shocked and confused but it's
but it's fascinating because i've
experienced this
that in the modern era these activists
actually tell people you can't succeed
that's what i'm saying because of your
race right so don't try it's their fault
who did it wouldn't have occurred to
them because that wasn't the case and
they're suddenly identified at a fairly
early age now i'm told that you are
different and you can't do things you
know that yeah that's what our
winsome sears our lieutenant governor in
virginia who was junkin's running mate
she said that's what crt does it makes
the the light in the child's eyes you
know if you tell you know and she she's
black herself and she said if you tell
black children
uh you can't succeed you're inherently
uh flawed
why why would we even think they would
try right of course they're gonna fall
you know into gangs and drugs because we
keep telling them that they're victims
and that they're hopeless
well you said it before but is it
surprising to anybody that the group of
people advocating for less population
are
favoring policies that result in
destroyed families destroyed economies
sterilization of children and outright
abortion of children the planned
parenthood thing i thought was a
conspiracy theory for years you know and
now they're having to grapple with it
by the way i'm a very late comer to
politics so i'm one of the people you
guys are talking about sometimes but but
you're a journalist margaret sanger um
you know was part of wanting to
apparently shape and annihilate you know
black population and now planned
parenthood is having to grapple with
that and on their website they address
this you know the fact that that was the
case and how they feel about that now
and you know that's a very tough thing
for them but oh i i read uh it was a
fact check i i think it was uh which one
one of those fact checkers maybe it was
the washington post we were just talking
i was just gonna bring that up saying
about the kkk rally because someone said
oh margaret singer spoke at kkk rallies
and so they did fact check about whether
that was true and they said no um
actually she only spoke at one event one
kkk event and it was a women's kkk event
it was like like the women who were
attached to the men in the kkk so it was
like a women's kkk event okay and and
she had she had a pure intention for
going there she was just trying to
spread her message of birth control to
whoever would listen so so they they
literally said it was okay that she went
to a kkk event because she was trying to
teach about birth control to everybody
no matter who would listen so she uh i
was just like
so hear what you're saying
insane i gotta address uh you know
michael malus who's a big friend of the
show and a good friend of mine
he's he's argued this is not true about
margaret sanger and you know recently
was talking to him and he was like no no
this is not true she was advocating for
birth control she was trying to end
poverty by telling these women and i'm
just like
i hear your argument dude
but i pulled up planned parenthood.org
that outright calls her racist she's a
eugenicist she was you know she's like
she's quoted planned parenthood calls
her racist yep she's actually i don't i
i i suppose it's you know i think
michael's a very smart guy and and i
respect him a whole lot but i don't
understand how
his point can be correct that she wasn't
maybe i got something wrong in in what
he was saying but they actually say she
believed in an inherently racist and
ableist ideology that labeled certain
people on unfit to have children she
believed in eugenics we denounced her
her beliefs in eugenics she she was
going to the black community
specifically telling them to stop having
kids
it sounds like she was racist you know i
don't know whatever a lot of everybody
was racist back then to to varying
degrees right they were racist against
irish people right yeah but and what's
so bizarre is that there's such a total
disconnect between
that fact and then the outcome of the
disparity of the proportion of black
children who are then killed you know i
think the ratio is like four or five
you know five to one black to white
babies but but yeah black people are
much smaller percentage of the
population so her vision has been
realized like she got what she was
dreaming for i was and that's what's
disgusting it's like playing her doesn't
acknowledge this i was watching a video
from it was actually some like critical
race theorist guy who pointed this out
it was like a black identitarian guy
saying
margaret sanger was racist planned
parenthood says she's racist and he uh
they were explaining how
uh
if the black population
wasn't getting abortion at the rate they
were there would be a substantially
larger portion of the u.s population by
now but you were mentioning it's like
five to one oh yeah yeah they were they
were um the the second largest minority
group ahead of latinos but because of
abortion black people are more likely to
abort than latinos now latinos have
suppressed uh surpassed black americans
as the biggest uh second biggest group
what was the was that was that the
conspiracy theory you're talking about
are you talking about selling baby parts
or something absolutely well
i found out about margaret sanger
because um an african-american
girlfriend and my brother some years ago
referred to
referred to it and it surprised me
because i had always just heard it in
passing and didn't put any thought into
that being possibly true but she said oh
black people know this and i i yeah so i
looked it up and
yeah yeah we had um daryl davis on and
he's gone relatively woke he used to
talk to members of the kkk and talk them
out of that ideology and he said that
his mother knew even then like a long
time ago she knew that they were like
trying to use black people that for
example we all know about you know the
tuskegee
experiments and stuff like that he said
that they understood that planned
parenthood was kind of a little bit of
an extension of that i'm paraphrasing
him i don't misquote him but my
understanding was that they knew that
that's what planned parenthood was going
for which was like really eye-opening
for me i was like they knew it was very
much common knowledge and it was just
one of those things they just accepted
it no but not only do they accept it
they promote it like they say
uh you know these white supremacists who
are pro-life they want to hold back
black women you know so it's a it's a
moral good for black women to want to
abort their children yeah and uh and
good on senator tim scott because he
called out uh janet yellen you know
janet yellen said uh you know if we had
you know fewer abortions in the past
than that we would have had a much
smaller gdp growth and tim scott said
you know as the as the you know black uh
son of a single mother i am so glad that
she did not share your view basically so
i just want to issue a clarification
according to planned parenthood they're
not selling tissue they're donating it
oh that's nice yeah so what about like
that
nobody else didn't project veritas yeah
i also ask people to look up because you
can find not the story but the the press
announcement abc a couple of years ago
with one of my former producers kim
skeen and chris wallace who worked at
abc at the time because kim kim turned
me onto this
back when you could cover normal stories
that people cared about in a normal way
as a journalist without getting canceled
they did a story on the
sale of body parts you know by fetal
body parts and the market among the
pharmaceutical industry and others for
clinical study and all kinds of things
and um
again that story is nowhere to be found
on the internet but if you google
or duck.go your choice whatever i mean
i mean uh abc's 2022 air report on fetal
tissue trafficking read a little bit of
that read about how much they were
paying for i think um a brain
there was literally a quote from one of
the directors of planned parenthood
saying she wanted to buy a new car
unbelievable so i don't care if they say
they're doing it i do not
today it's project veritas what i'm
telling you is not long ago abc news
and chris wallace were doing this kind
of reporting when reporters were you
know more open to doing neutral stories
on important controversies
and so so the organization i don't
believe it was um i don't believe it was
uh oh man i'm blanking on name veritas
it was the center for medical progress
and what they did is after they filmed
these
these employees of planned parenthood
and representatives haggling over the
price of fetal tissue
they edited it yes but they placed the
full unedited footage on the internet
for anyone to watch if they wanted to
and they got in trouble right like
everything on the news is edited at some
point if it's not just a full raw
hour-long tape so well and the reason if
i understand probably that david deliden
actually got in trouble was just because
of uh two-party consent laws with
respect to filming people it wasn't
because he edited anything deceptively
or dishonestly right
that was an argument yeah of course that
used to not be an argument and i saw
that raise when i was doing at cbs not
about me but when people wanted to make
controversies all of a sudden
opposing people politically would say
that tape was edited and like yeah all
of our tapes are edited everything and
people who are deceptively editing a
tape do not place the entirety of the
footage online for everyone to be able
to watch it
so this was a big story in 2015.
undercover video shows planned
parenthood official discussing fetal
organs used for research
they responded to it saying it's tissue
donation
but in the video she and so in the the
footage
the uh the woman literally says
there
whoever throws out a figure in a
negotiation first loses
yeah that you know the thing you say
when you're donating something to
somebody
insanity
but what is donation right they don't
know what words mean or they don't use
them properly they are intentionally
accepted you know what does donation
mean you say you're paying for
time and transportation of the stuff and
to have it preserved so that there's all
kinds of ways to say you're not paying
for the tissue but in fact sheamus i'm
going to donate this uh loctionary to
you thank you so much hey can you spot
me 20 bucks yeah of course man you got
to make a profit off your donations
that's right yeah no no no no
he didn't you got to pay for the lights
and that he was sitting here yeah he
didn't sell me anything i just had the
effort you had to use to
the planned parenthood defense would
catch on with the irs like no that was
not that wasn't work i didn't sell that
that was not i donated that but i mean i
happened to make money but it was
something tells me that the the irs
isn't going to be concerned about that
federal agencies are not going to go
after the left in this way ever ever
look at what happened with donald trump
and russia gate
one of the one of the biggest con i mean
not now we're looking at the suspend
trial with all with with with what's
going on hillary clinton knowing about
and signing off on a lot of the stuff
some of the most shocking revelations
we've heard in a long time russia gate
was staged it was fake it was a hoax
tricking the government the many
elements of the government the fbi knew
it was fake they went after it anyway
wow it was gonna be like how many of
them were really tricked so we got a
couple guys which was part of his
defense actually the assessment that was
his defense was like well they already
knew so i wasn't actually
it was immaterial if i was lying well in
the fbi's defenses we didn't know that
they're such bad at their job so they're
supposed to be top federal agents that
they don't even do due diligence when a
political operative brings them research
on one of the most sensitive things they
could do which is someone an opposing
political campaign
my sources at fbi tell me they used to
not go you know within
a mile of an investigation like that it
was so controversial just to avoid any
appearance of conflict they stayed away
from journalists and political figures
at least the honest guys and now we're
to believe that they didn't even do due
diligence when they're handed you know
opposition research well it was because
he they he knew him personally because
sustainment had worked formally at the
fbi and even so they should have
questioned the guy who met with james
baker was my former professor at uh
harvard law school uh actually a good
person like and he and he's the one who
i think is uh at the center of the
damning text messages that he's reported
so good on him so uh wow yeah
was well do we know if he lied or if he
just got passionate in the moment and
then walked it back it was a passionate
text message
they're walking it back now it's a joke
okay the whole thing though
can't wait for them to apologize saying
double standard dave smith at this point
it's like nails on a chalkboard because
he's like yes yes we know we know it's
it's not it's
it's you know some 16 year old is going
to start watching the news and then go
to his dad and be like dad there's a
double standard he's going to go
oh son i remember when i thought that
was going to be the case yeah i think
it's uh dave smith and uh robbie
bernstein always make this joke like oh
no we're waiting for an apology on that
it's going to come any day they're going
to apologize anyway any day i'm sure i'm
sure carter page last time i checked the
former trump campaign associate who was
improperly spied upon with doctored
evidence from the fbi who by the way had
never met or talked to or communicated
with donald trump directly but through a
wiretap improperly done on carter page
donald trump's communications could be
captured the way they allow themselves
to capture all the communications of
those in orbit around the one wiretap
person to this day as far as i know he
has not received so much as an apology
in fact
his efforts at his own expense to try to
get some
let's say equity in court over all that
happened to him have just gone
unanswered his case has been thrown out
the fbi has not said so much as you know
now that we've convicted the one lawyer
if nothing else of doctoring a document
in your case we're sorry nothing you
know just standing oh he only got
probation he got like i think like 400
hours of community service although he
should have spent a year in jail thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you